el grupo de segundo grado de la señora
grande tiene 45 pelotas de tenis para
jugar en el recreo 19 pelotas se volaron
por encima de la barda y 6 pelotas
simplemente desaparecieron cuántas
pelotas de tenis le quedan al grupo de
la señora grench y bueno la verdad es
que siempre que estoy haciendo un
ejercicio de estos me gusta ir anotando
la información que me van dando aunque
por aquí nos están diciendo que el grupo
tiene 45 pelotas de tenis 45 pelotas de
tenis el grupo de la señora grandes
tiene 45 pelotas de tenis y luego
también nos dice que 19 de esas pelotas
se volaron por encima de la barda y que
además 6 pelotas simplemente
desaparecieron aunque el grupo de la
señora granxa empezó con 45 pelotas de
tenis pero luego 19 pelotas se volaron
por encima de la barda y 6 pelotas
desaparecieron
y luego queremos saber cuántas pelotas
de tenis le quedan al grupo de la señora
grande y en este tipo de problemas hay
que pensar por dónde empezamos por aquí
el segundo grado de la señora grande
empieza con 45 pelotas de tenis pero
después pierde las pelotas aunque hay 19
pelotas se volaron por encima de la
barda eso es perder pelotas y luego 6
pelotas simplemente desaparecieron
eso también es perder pelotas y como
estamos perdiendo pelotas lo que tenemos
que hacer es restar y otra pista que nos
dice que tenemos que restar en este
ejercicio se encuentra en esta pregunta
ok por qué nos preguntan que cuántas
pelotas de tenis le quedan al grupo de
la señora grande que puede estar
implicando que el grupo de la señora
grande no tiene todas las pelotas con
las que empezó pero pues no es una pista
muy precisa y la verdad es que todo lo
que necesitamos saber se encuentra por
aquí
empezamos con 45 pelotas de tenis y
luego perdemos 19 pelotas o sea que
queremos restar 19 pelotas
empezamos con 45 pelotas y 19 se volaron
por encima de la barda y por eso las
estamos restando porque se perdieron
estas pelotas entonces tenemos por aquí
5 unidades y le queremos restar 9
unidades pero 5 es más chico que 9
entonces vamos a hacer una reagrupación
aunque hay aquí tenemos 4 de escenas y
vamos a pedir prestada una decena
entonces nos quedan tres decenas más la
decena que pedimos prestada que la vamos
a convertir a 10 unidades y entonces 10
más 5 son 15 unidades y ahora si hacemos
la resta 15 menos 9 son 6 y luego tres
decenas menos una decena esas son
decenas entonces tenemos 26 ahora ya
terminamos pues no porque este número es
el número de pelotas que quedan después
de que se vuelan 19 pelotas pero antes
de que desaparezcan las otras 6 pelotas
aunque ya estamos como en este punto del
problema nos falta restar estas 6
pelotas que desaparecieron entonces
hagamos eso tenemos 26 pelotas de tenis
aunque ayer porque teníamos 45 pelotas y
se volaron 19 entonces ahora tenemos 26
pelotas pero seis de esas pelotas
desaparecieron y como desaparecieron
pues las tenemos que restar entonces
vamos a restar seis pelotas
hagamos la resta tenemos 6 unidades
menos 6 unidades
nos quedan 0 unidades y dos decenas
menos cero decenas esas son dos decenas
y ahora sí cuántas pelotas de tenis le
quedan al grupo de la señora grande pues
lo tenemos aquí le quedan 20 pelotas
empezamos con 45 pelotas de las cuales
19 se vuelan por encima de la barda y
entonces nos quedan 26 pelotas pero de
esas 26 pelotas 6 desaparecen entonces
restamos 6 y nos quedan 20 pelotas en
total